bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors d'abord
quels sont les arguments que vous
comptez faire valoir contre edouard
philippe et agnès buzyn les arguments
qu'on a fait valoir sont relativement
simples
il pèse sur chacun une obligation de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposent pour
faire face à un sinistre
là c'est très clair madame busin
monsieur philippe n'ont pas pris les
mesures se sont abstenu volontairement
de prendre les mesures qu'il fallait
madame suzanne lareau quand les colonnes
du monde qui a plus de débat sur ce
témoin
ils se sont abstenu volontairement non
pas parce qu'il ne savait pas mais parce
qu'effectivement il savait et on fait un
choix délibéré de ne pas commander les
masques de ne pas effectivement
s'organiser et de mentir aux français
voilà d'ailleurs agnès buzyn elle a fait
une déclaration dans le monde c'était il
ya plus d'une dizaine de jours elle
affirme avoir alerté
le premier ministre edouard philippe sur
les risques encourus en maintenant
justement le premier tour des élections
municipales vous en pensez quoi
je pense que je pense de choses je pense
que nous avons perdu la raison
la raison d'état on a perdu la raison
d'état dans ce pays
on est en train de m'expliquer que le
ministre de la santé qui est une femme
par ailleurs ultra compétente et qui a
été voué sa carrière à la gestion
sanitaire et bien alerte les autorités
sanitaires les autorités ministérielles
et que non seulement entre les ministres
ne fait rien le président de la
république ne peut rien mais qu' elle
même ne fait rien et que le directeur
général de la santé ne fut rien alors si
ça c'est pas un scandale d'état
j'attends que mon donne la définition
alors outre les plaintes il ya déjà
trois recours devant le conseil d'état
tout se rejetaient on en parlait tout à
l'heure
est-ce que pensez vous que vous aurez
davantage de chance alors d'abord le
conseil d'état n'a pas réellement rejeté
les requêtes j'écoutais le président du
smer
je pense qu'il faut lire les décisions
le problème qui se pose dans ce pays
c'est que vous voulez faire dire ou aux
juridictions ce qui n'est pas leur rôle
quelque part le conseil d'état est une
juridiction
j'ai entendu une administration non le
conseil d'état est un juge indépendant
et impartial et qu'est ce qu'il a dit il
concédé il s'est contenté de dire vous
voulez que je fasse injonction au
ministre d'avoir à vous fournir des
masques il y en a pas de masque donc ce
faisant le conseil d'état reconnaît que
le ministre a commis une faute mais que
je peux pas effectivement obligé le
ministre à me fournir ce qu'il n'a pas
mais la consécration d'une faute elle
est remarquable
moi je vais m'en servir à des arrêts du
conseil d'état demain matin je vais
envoyer en complément de ma plainte à la
cour de justice de la république
cet arrêt du conseil d'état n'a regardé
le conseil d'état vous dis bah oui mais
il ya bien sûr que c'est nécessaire les
masques pour défendre le droit à la vie
vous avez besoin des masques mais y'en a
pas bah voilà donc effectivement il
aurait fallu qu'il y en ait merci
monsieur le conseil d'état c'est ça je
vous dis alors pourquoi ses parents
qu'elle a plus de chance
d'abord parce que j'ai pas saisi le
conseil d'état mais la cour de justice
de la république
je veux dire saisir le conseil d'état
pour ordonné en référé que tout le monde
soit protégé on est des masques pour
tout le monde c'est après le mariage
pour tous les masques pour tous on en a
pas effectivement de masque on en a pas
c'est bien tout le problème
on n'en a pas qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on avait cherché on nous annonce
maintenant qui vont arriver passé ce
délai les images qui sont arrivés
aujourd'hui au passage à raison de deux
millions et demi sur les 5 millions on
en a pas donc le conseil d'état a fait
preuve de pragmatisme judiciaire en
disant oui c'est vrai c'est vrai vous
avez raison vous aurez vous avez droit à
des masques oui vous avez raison mais
y'en a pas voilà est-ce que votre timing
il est bon mon timing en fait il est
celui effectivement que me fixer lois de
la république je vais vous poser la
question différemment
est ce que si j'ai vu que des
pharmaciens à la ont été accusés d'avoir
vendu des masques que celle de manière
illégale ou qu'ils ont commis une
infraction pénale le parquet ne s'est
pas posé la question de savoir s'il
attendait la fin de l'épidémie pour les
poursuivre le temps de la justice
il est effectivement le temps de la
justice qui est en confinement
aujourd'hui c'est les populations c'est
pas le droit
si le président de la république si la
ministre de la justice souhaitait qu'on
interrompe les plaintes pendant le temps
du confinement il avec elle dira mais
moi je suis citoyen de la république et
à ce titre des clients également on
utilise l'état de droit et point dans
l'état de droit'' dit que à n'importe
quel moment on a le droit de déposer une
plainte et donc ya pas de temps
favorable sinon celui que fit la loi et
plus globalement le regard que vous
portez sans la gestion par le
gouvernement de cette crise sanitaire
alors le regard que je porte il est le
suivant c'est que ça témoigne de deux
choses sept moines qu'effectivement la
politique a envahi toutes les sphères de
l'état et que ça devient un véritable
problème
ce gouvernement a fait semblant de
regarder ailleurs pendant que la maison
brûle et l'année dernière c'est notre
dame qui brûlait quasiment à la même
époque
cette année c'est le pays tout entier
qui brûle et de la même façon qu'on n'a
pas été capable d'anticiper le moindre
incendie de notre dame par des mesures
de protection haddock
on l'a vu l'année dernière on n'est pas
capable effectivement d'anticiper une
épidémie qui nous pendait au nez
on regarde si vous voulez il est
relativement simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes face à un mensonge d'état
nous sommes face à un gouvernement dans
lequel la confiance est ébranlée
durablement et moi mon inquiétude c'est
autant comment sortir de l'épidémie que
comment l'état de droit va ressortir de
tout ça il va le ressortir dans le même
état que les patients effectivement
2 qu'est passion tout perdu la vie dans
le cadre de l'animation ce qu'est ce que
nous avons perdu
si vous voulez pour terminer dans cette
affaire c'est toute confiance dans ce
gouvernement est dans la capacité de
l'état à protéger les populations
un gouvernement qui s'appuie on le
rappelle est il le rappelle très souvent
d'ailleurs sur un comité scientifique se
diot justement qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
j'en pense que d'abord pour que le
gouvernement arrête de mentir et vous
savez pour les municipales vous souvenez
que effectivement le gouvernement a dit
qu'il s'est appuyé sur l'avis du conseil
scientifique pour les maintenir
oui bah alors une fois les biens de
l'avis du conseil scientifique
moi je vous invite vous invite tous ceux
qui nous regardent aller lien avec des
comités scientifiques et si quelqu'un
trouve que le comité scientifique a dit
qu'il fallait maintenir les municipales
et ben ok d'accord sauf que c'est parce
que des comités scientifiques
le comité scientifique dit le maintien
des municipales est une décision
éminemment politique
si vous voulez maintenir des municipales
si vous voulez les maintenir
il faut effectivement prendre un certain
nombre de mesures etc mais en aucun cas
que le conseil scientifique ne le valide
les élections municipales
donc quelle parole quelle confiance
peut-on encore avoir dans la parole de
ce gouvernement
regardez pour les masquer il paraît
qu'ils sont commandés mais ça fait
combien de temps qu'ils ont commandé ces
masques ça fait combien de temps nous on
a fait délivrer une sommation par
huissier au ministre de la santé d'abord
à nous justifier les commandes s'il a
rien à cacher la cible et donne qui nous
donne les contraintes et les factures la
vérité si vous voulez c'est que ce
gouvernement non et il ment en
permanence en permanence pourquoi parce
qu'il a du mal à dissimuler l'état
d'impréparation et d'amateurisme avec
lequel effectivement il dirige le pays
aujourd'hui face à cette crise c'est
tout merci beaucoup fabrice di vizio je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat du
collectif plaignants merci d'avoir réagi
en direct sur arte france